an island surrounded by beer souls
mushrooms and asparagus vegetarian
dishes as beautiful as a painting
arranged with artistry unusual
ingredients including purple carrots
a coral reef made of parmesan even the
deserts are almost too beautiful to eat
this ball of chocolate hides a secret
lemon sorbet with a delicate sweet
biscuit file which is the man behind
these works of art his father is
Croatian his mother Austrian Eva to
learned his trade in Switzerland Germany
and Austria although he sometimes it's
meat eh has become a fan of vegetarian
cuisine it's elegant rather than rustic
made with imagination and featuring
choice ingredients such as truffles feed
in English it's that convenience many
might call it decadent but I don't think
so
because this is all a gift from nature
sure the price may be high but when we
talk about the culinary arts we should
have respect for what nature has to
offer and it gives me great pleasure to
be able to cook with these special
ingredients
today the truffles will go into a russet
to eat when it comes to purely
vegetarian restaurants even gourmet
eateries often find that premium prices
are a hard sell with customers but the
effort and expense involved in
vegetarian cuisine can be even higher
than traditional meat and fish based
cooking NTN a lunch dish costs 32 euros
in the evening menus with several
courses run between 80 and 120 euros in
vienna capital of the Vienna schnitzel
such vegetarian cuisine as a culinary
novelty both quality and passion make
the difference convincing our guests was
difficult in the beginning of course but
meanwhile I think vegetarian cuisine can
hold its own alongside schnitzel in
Chinese Tian means heaven or sky and
food critics agree paul ii [ __ ]
cooking is heavenly he's been awarded 1
star by the michelin gourmet restaurant
guide and three chokes by guru your
vegetarian cuisine is finally coming
into its own did you get how to Cuba
vegetarian cuisine at least in Austria
has a kind of whole grain image it's
always been seen as sort of alternative
not really about pleasure but about
healthy eating this kiss one day it's
not that's true no what's nice nowadays
is that healthy eating has as much
status as creativity in flavor and it's
all come together
Alistair salmon fin de Polly which
spends up to 16 hours a day in his
restaurant that makes his leisure time
all the more valuable coltan is some
yoga cooking for me isn't like yoga but
I also do real yoga play tennis with my
brother and soccer with friends full
sparsh PT t on opened in 2011 in the
centre of Vienna
at first some guests just ordered a
salad and a glass of water
but meanwhile more and more customers
are open to vegetarian experimentation
indica table I'm not a vegetarian if I
was skeptical and wondered if it would
be filling but it is it's amazing what
you can do with natural ingredients and
vegetables I didn't expect all these
really interesting flavors here today
because you've men in common either
female or this kind of odd cuisine is
hard to recreate at home that's why I
found average also compiled some simpler
recipes for his cookbook here assert the
NZ save again on we should all pay
attention to what promotes our well
being your food should be your medicine
and vice versa
I'd say eating 80% meat or fish free
meals would do us good for tourism here
in Vienna poly which has already won
over many carnivals to his way of eating